whatsapp signori sono johnny green oggi
ragazzi siamo su un gioco un po
particolare perché è un horror
abbastanza peso che è da un po che stavo
guardando la doppiando rimorchiando si
chiama paper dolls
allora ragazzi già che parte con un
caricamento che dice nascondersi a volte
la migliore opzione
direi che stiamo parlando di un gioco
serio prove c'è una galleria molto figo
vorrei saper guidare per poter dire lo
stesso
io credo che oggi oddio che cosa è
successo in partenza per idonei a
originale va bene però in galera ci
siamo cappottati viva i segnali stradali
c'è una bambina bambina io ero in
galleria stavo guidando bambini bambina
successo alla mia figlia a figlia ha
inteso svenuto ma perché io devo
iniziare tutti gli horror con uno
schianto incredibile poi risveglio poi
nel quell'altro c'erano le altre
macchine prima ma adesso siamo mica nel
mondo di silent hill non c'è mica più
nessuno niente la metà del video di che
tenta di alzarsi va bene va bene io ero
in autostrada con la macchina e sono
finite in una casa dove c'è una statua
rotta tra l'altro col sangue senza un
motivo
ue bambina sono qua sono nella stanza
quello con la statua morta per terra
vabbè se c'è qua un cacciavite con il
demonio che schifo
la madonna c'è questa c'era arrivata ai
ma che schifo
nel diario pino quanno chiove a devo
girare proprio
ecco mavava angular a sto punto gira
cosa infatti fare prima che news.it a
passare il panno ma non era un panno era
dello scotch
vabbè dai allora parte lo potevi girare
anche se tra maniglia a quel punto prova
bene senza delon boss stabili che ruba
per ii che parti dunque ho trovato una
chiave che non ho ben capito che chiave
è però posso leggere nella lock and kids
le varie però non ho capito la chiave sì
però scusami ok una chiave con un culo
un po strano che va bene è esattamente
questa qua quindi il lucchetto tipo
questo qui può essere vediamo legge o
ragazzi e lo trova subito emma ma
rimette tutto il gioco consiste nel
trovare robe e nascondersi da qualche
mostro eventuale perché effettivamente
soprano non fate scherzi altra chiave
questo posso aprire effettivamente
l'altro lucchetto che stava dietro
credo che cacchio è a minchia possa
accendere l'incenso è fatto veramente
bene suo gioco ma dove arione 21 suoni
sony jam scarpe stromae questo posto è
totalmente sicuro perché benedetto non
ho divinità amica che culo normale e
quindi ha quindi adesso quando mi spunta
satana posso venire qua tranquillamente
vabbè ragazzi ora torniamo indietro per
vedere se effettivamente eccolo qua
questa l'altro pezzo di questa porta dal
lucchetto belzebù vieni a me beh però
allegro spero che non vista che l'ha
vista della grafica non è niente male
spero sia un gioco abbastanza carino a
livello di mostri ma la grafica può far
cose degli art prize
porca [ __ ] mano su lasciato a mani
basse la madonnina che cacchio è salve
tutto a posto allora secchione ha di
nuovo wqs ce l'ho fatta a corri la
madonna e ad anno dove premere tante
volte
minchia alla v
ma che è sta vecchia le vecchie volanti
le vecchie volanti che brutta roba da
avere ragazzi alla prima andare avanti
andando a destra effettivamente è andata
la zia la zia non è proprio a lei
culmine sono tra chiave di lavandino
andiamo di l'animo di qua quindi bello
che il personaggio biscione non corre
neanche per sbaglio cioè non colli non
corre perché lui non ha voglia ricorre
non corriamo vediamo di riuscire a usare
la chiave che ho trovato
da porca [ __ ] no no a posto ragazzi
paper dolls ma vorrei fatto benissimo
non è vero molli come le capsule da un
più fruibile a mia figlia veramente ho
trovato la chiave cielo il mio coniglio
che cazzo dici equa la chiave come la
posso usare ma cosa ma porco di mamma
come veramente
oddio è che chi lo fa
c'è un'altra porta e che l'aveva vista
questa lega molli tesoro sto arrivando
come le capsule molli oddio di oddio
posso salvare la partita prima che mi
afferrino delle mani orribili posso
salvare la partita non posso fare la
partita
sono uscito cosa adesso c'è c'è un
baratro non uscire
addio decina dall'altra parte c'è un
baratro ovunque ma veramente o cristo e
laddove sono uscito io guardati allo
specchio ala flashlight è troppo ok ecco
allora lì a destra e adesso c'è una
parte verde va bene
[Musica]
enter nou air sono entrato nel know
where ecco la chiave ha funzionato
ragazzi sono un fenomeno queste cagate
comunque me ne rendo conto
va bene io vorrei sapere la partita
prima che mi ammazzino cosa che è già
successa non avrei successivo può fare
sono nell'altrove ragazzi altrove è la
cittadini leone cane fifone e anche
quella di insidious effettivamente fosse
un piano di somma veramente prenderà
anche lì sopra c'è un coniglio li cos'è
il ragazzo credibile cosa sta roba
ciao si bruttissimo e la madonna aiuto
corri forte prima che ti direi masi così
eccola è sempre schiacciato a coltellate
che lo schiaccia porco demoni ma
costellato da marocco fa male fu più di
chi minchia l'ha mai schiaccia tv più di
shift run vai cori ma non corre non è
vero non corre 2 vado modo di qua vari
quadri qua con ripam destra destra posto
sbagliato però sempre dato un'importa
vai vai vai vai vai vai maicon ricordi
puledro corrie novari shall pass
eccolo qua control unit e let's go hide
and seek nascondino adesso c'è il mostro
che mi segue mi sembrava strano che
ancora mi avesse seguito nessuno
comunque ragazzo trovato una bava gip a
chi lacca una vai a questo qua che mi ha
pugnalato prima ok io posso teoricamente
pugnale alla gente
con la gente intendo questo qua questo
porta non era per tapino wang yong no
non fare casino scusami scusa non
volevano perché le balle o ci sono
oggetti o schiaccio pace il tabacco che
la faccio altro tommaso bello lo
prendiamo sempre visto che arriva via
via via via via via via cioè brutto
gioco che ha voluto stata una partita
bella sta porta quindi in green dini
cosa devo farmene quindi ha funzionato
ma dai ma io che ne so
a devo premerli in un certo ordine io
non ho solo stamattina vigore sia
fantastico qualcuno ha scoraggiato ho
sentito una pernacchia da qualche parte
che non ho capito quale dovrebbe essere
ma non ho non so come ci sarà un modo
per se c'è un modo troviamo in fretta
ragazzi ma proprio velocissimi proprio
velocissimi proprio che devi correre ad
1 2 3 4 5 e 6 a caso era quello giusto
mi sa di no ti prego non venire qui
porco il demonio porco porco
ti prego ma vi ammazzo i ragazzi che
sarà il primo episodio di payrolls molto
figo molto carino molto infarto zoe
molto giapponese spero che gli sia
piaciuto cile al secondo episodio
speriamo non sia niente di strano
iscritti al canale lanciato mi piace e
ci avevano proseguito bella ragazza
[Musica]